thank you
it's 10 o'clock this is Sky News at 10
our top story
the head of the RAF is ready to test the
limit of the law to improve diversity in
the force
the Revelation is made in leaked
transcripts in the latest in a series of
Sky News investigations on RAF
recruitment claims that someone's broken
the law then of course they will face
the consequences for that
we'll see tonight the king says he will
support a study into the British
monarchy's historic links to slavery
welcomed diplomacy the French president
tells China to bring Russia to its
senses and come back to the negotiating
table with Ukraine
back in Paris one of the French
president's favorite restaurants was set
on fire as tens of thousands of
protesters take to the streets
the emergency alert to warn the public
of dangerous situations to be tested
later this month
and the lionesses penalty shootout win
the first women's finalismer in front of
a crowd of more than 80 000 at Wembley
plus we'll take a first look at
tomorrow's front pages in our press
preview from 10 30.
[Music]
a very good evening the head of the
royal Air Force has signaled he would
bend his service out of shape and test
the limit of the law to improve
diversity that's according to a leaked
transcript of an internal meeting it's
the latest in a series of Sky News
investigations on RAF recruitment claims
which led to MP's questioning air Chief
Marshals sir Mike wigston who has always
maintained that necessary and
well-intentioned efforts to increase the
ratio of ethnic minority and female
recruits had no impact on the raf's
operational effectiveness but now a
serving RAF Airman has told Sky News
that the service is struggling due to a
lack of recruitment our security and
defense editor Deborah Haynes has this
exclusive report
better diversity has been a key goal for
the Royal Air Force under its outgoing
chief a well-intentioned Dame but with
unintended consequences after the head
of recruitment quit last year in protest
at an allegedly illegal order to
discriminate against white men
it's a controversy still hanging over
the RAF headquartered here at High
Wycombe with air Chief Marshals sir Mike
wigston preparing to leave office soon
Sky News can reveal new details about
conversations on diversity that
allegedly took place behind the scenes
I've been told by a source that in June
2022 the Air Force's top Personnel
officer in correspondence to staff said
air Chief Marshall wigston was prepared
to bend what's known as the operational
inflow requirement for the RAF out of
shape over the next three years to meet
levels of ambition when it came to
diversity
the air Chief has always insisted his
important drive for more women and
ethnic minorities was never at the
expense of the services warfighting
needs there was no compromise of Entry
standards there was no impact on the the
standard of recruits from any background
there was no impact on the front line or
on operational effectiveness
an Airman sharing his views anonymously
offered a different perspective he said
us on the shop floor so to speak a
struggling we haven't got enough people
to do the jobs and are desperate to have
new recruits new people constantly
Sky News has seen a leaked transcript
from a meeting in June 2020 between the
head of the RAF and the Air Force's
black Asian and minority ethnic Network
it gave a sense of air Chief Marshall
wigston's understandable passion about
lifting the ratio of ethnic minority
recruits in the service from around six
percent to 20 percent by 2030
if change didn't happen fast enough he
said I'm going to take it as far as I
can in the law right up to the point of
quotas and push positive action to the
limit of the law two years later this
woman group Captain Elizabeth Nichol
resigned as head of recruitment after
refusing to implement what she allegedly
deemed to be an illegal order to
prioritize female and ethnic minority
recruits over white men for training
slots an inquiry into what happened has
yet to be published but the defense
secretary said anyone to be found at
fault would be held to account
and if someone's broken the law then of
course they will face the consequences
for that like ultimately and what what
what people need to understand is that
no one was prevented from joining the
RAF as a result of these conditions an
RAF spokesperson said During the period
in question our selection standards did
not drop and there was no impact on the
operational effectiveness of the RAF
however in hindsight we accept that
despite the best of intentions that some
mistakes were made
the raf's now confident its approach to
recruitment is correct but that slim
comfort for those already impacted
Deborah Haynes Sky News
the king is backing a study exploring
the relationship between the British
Monarchy and slavery in the 17th and
18th centuries
statement released this morning the
palace said that King Charles takes the
issue extremely seriously seriously it
was in response to this document that
emerged in the guardian newspapers
showing at King William the third stake
in a slave trading company worth a
thousand pounds
the shares were transferred from the
slave trader Edward coulston a figure
made more famous when his statue was
toppled and thrown into Bristol Harbor
in 2020
it's not the only historic connection
between a monarchy and the slave trade
back in the reign of Queen Elizabeth the
First the Monarch gave a royal ship to
slave trader John Hawkins in exchange
for a share of the profits of his voyage
more than 400 African people were
captured and sold into slavery as a
result
then in the 18th century King George II
was the governor of the south sea
company which took 41
923 African captives on its ships
between 1714 and 1740 more than seven
thousand people died on those voyages
while speaking about the legacy of those
links King Charles has said I cannot
describe the depths of my personal
sorrow at the suffering of so many as I
continue to deepen my own understanding
of slavery's enduring impact
well it was an issue that followed the
king and queen consort to York today as
they attended the Monday Thursday
service along with cheers from the well
wishes and team monarchy protesters
turned out chanting not my king Skies
north of England correspondent shingy
mararike reports
[Applause]
[Music]
King arriving in York for a
centuries-old tradition
the Royal mondi Service
dating back to 1210 it's either Monarch
handing out specially minted coins to
those who have served their churches and
communities
but today King Charles also acknowledged
a darker chapter in his family's past
pledging his support for a study into
their links to slavery for the first
time
in the face of regular protests
not seen by his mother the late Queen
his attempts to be a progressive King
will see the institution he represents
question now more than ever
promising to look into the Royal
Family's ties to the slave trade is a
matter the king says he takes profoundly
seriously with research expected to end
in 2026 but the protesters here Phil
those answers need to be more urgent
well I don't think they've really been
explicit about it I think that they will
always fudge it they've not really
acknowledged their own personal
um Legacy and it's difficult people
might say look you know Towers isn't
responsible for you know George III but
he takes his position as king because of
George III so you can't remember both
ways
Colonial Legacy is why some nations are
looking to lose the king as their head
of state I think that it would make a
great deal of difference uh to me but
many peop many people in the in the in
the British Commonwealth particularly in
the Caribbean if the royal family
knowledge not only that they were
representative of a Nation uh in
involved in slavery but they had
personal links as as well well the month
until the coronation those complex
contentious debates around issues like
this will continue
here in York opinion was divided to say
he's not okay well he is It's All About
Kids isn't it whether they like it or
not
entitled to their opinions but they're
so valuable and so angry about it seems
unnecessary really
it's clear there's the monarchy moves
into a new era one of the main questions
for now and the future is how it deals
with the issues of the past shinky
barike Sky News
the Chinese leader has been urged by
Europe to bring Russia to its senses
French president Emmanuel macron and the
European commissioner Ursula vondeline
have been in Beijing for diplomatic
talks Xi Jinping was warned that
supplying weapons to Moscow would have
significant consequences Sky's Asia
correspondent helenanne Smith reports
there's been a parade of leaders through
Beijing in recent weeks
but few have been met with a welcome
like this
China rolled out the red carpet for
president macron both literally and
metaphorically
but for all the show there's still more
than just a language barrier between
these two leaders merci beaucoup
at the negotiating table there was much
to discuss a war in Ukraine and China's
position on it
the Russian aggression in Ukraine has
dealt a blow to this stability and put
an end to Decades of Peace in Europe and
I know that I can count on you to bring
Russia to reason and everyone to the
negotiating table
China claims it's neutral in the war but
these scenes in Moscow last month
indicate otherwise
even here aside macron she made it clear
Russia's interests shouldn't be
forgotten
take into account the legitimate
security concerns of all parties seek
political resolutions and build a
balanced effective and sustainable
European security framework
this Mission clearly matters the EU
commission boss is here too to push it
the real fear is what happens if China
goes further and sells arms to Russia
arming the aggressor is a clear
violation of international law it's the
aggressor and he should never be armed
and this would indeed significantly harm
the relationship between the European
Union and China a threat made more
stinging by being delivered on Chinese
soil but will it land
a relationship with Europe has value for
China not just economically but also as
a buffer against its plummeting
relations with America but it also has
lots of reasons why it doesn't want to
see Russia weakened and defeated it's
therefore very possible the visits like
this won't make much difference
indeed China's number one goal is to
protect the interests of China for now
it's careful Balancing Act is most
likely to remain Helena Smith Sky News
in Beijing
[Music]
Richie sunak has said that no further
action will be taken against former Tory
Chief whip Mark Spencer after an inquiry
failed to determine whether he had told
a conservative MP her Muslim faith was a
factor in her sacking nazrat ghani
claimed she was told her muslimness was
raised as an issue when she lost her job
as a minister in 2020. muskai's
political correspondent Alan Fortescue
joins me now from Westminster Ali this
was a three-year investigation what
happened
well Sally let's go back to the
beginning nurse ghani was your first
ever female conservative Muslim MP to be
elected in the House of Commons she was
sacked in 2020 she was a transport
Minister she says at the time Mark
Spencer the then Chief whip said part of
the reason for that was as she put it
her muslimness that was raised as an
issue that was making people feel
uncomfortable well there was a
long-awaited cabinet office review today
that reviewers effectively said that
this is a he said she said situation
there is not enough evidence or Rudy
part of the report despite a review of
considerable evidence it has not been
possible to draw a clear picture of what
was discussed Ms Garney and Mr Spencer
have differing accounts of these
meetings with different Recollections of
what was said so Mark Spencer has
effectively been cleared of any
wrongdoing he has though been criticized
for the way that this meeting was was
handled the fact that it happened in
private nuzgani today standing by her
allegations the Prime Minister though I
think very keen to draw a line under
this he says no further actions going to
be taken but this is an interesting I
think example of a report that is
slightly more Nuance slightly less
clear-cut certainly if you compare it to
Nadeem zahawi who is very quickly sacked
and of course coming down the tracks
remember is the investigation into
Dominic Robb we expect that to come back
soon that may well end up being a very
difficult decision for ishisunak
very much
the new leader of the SMP in Scotland's
first Minister Hamza Yousaf has told Sky
News that governance of the party is not
as good as it should be it comes after
the police finally finished searching
the home of Nicholas sturgeon and her
husband Peter Morrill over SNP finances
Mr Morrill was arrested yesterday and
later released without charge as part of
the investigation our Scotland
correspondent Connor Gillis reports
detectives departing after more than 30
hours time spent scouring the home of
ex-smp Chief Peter Morrow the husband of
Nicola sturgeon
evidence gathering in a place police are
focused on as part of an investigation
on SNP funding and finances a probe that
led to the arrest and later release of
Morrow
well in Scott's law you can be arrested
and not charged but only held for a
maximum of 12 hours the purpose of that
12 hours is really to gather information
about potential crimes the pending
investigation means they are going to
look through all that material entering
the home of the new leader of Scotland
the official residence of Hamza Yusuf
someone now attempting to reset after
the departure of the country's political
power couple you touched on governance
and transparency within the party that
you're now leading is that an admission
that things were not quite right over
the course of the last couple of years
under Peter model's War that's an
admission that our governance our
transparency should have been better was
Nicholas urgent too dominant in your
view I think in her own view in her own
words she was a dominant political force
there's now an opportunity with her no
longer the leader of the party with
Peter no longer the chief executive to
have a different way of doing things
this has been a long-running probe
stretching back to March 2021 when a
complaint was launched with police about
six hundred thousand pounds raised to
support a second Independence referendum
that made the SNP National Treasurer
resigned citing Financial transparency
concerns by John July detectives launch
Operation Branch form amid seven
complaints fast forward to December 2022
accounts commission reports say Peter
Morrow provided a personal loan of more
than a hundred thousand pounds to the
SMP around 18 months before by March
after decades at the top he quit after a
row over dwindling membership numbers
this Saga will no doubt be weighing
heavy on Nicholas sturgeon who has not
been seen in public she was due to
appear here at this venue in Edinburgh
to discuss climate change but pulled out
a sign that the crisis in her personal
life was at risk of overshadowing
proceedings
as the police presence moves away the
job of sifting and scrutinizing any
evidence begins Connor Gillis Sky News
well president macron remains in China
protesters have again taken to the
streets of Paris over his plans to raise
the retirement age they set fire to a
restaurant in a city known to be one of
Mr macron's favorite places to eat our
correspondent Adele Robinson reports
anger engulfing the streets of Paris
once again
with an attack on a famous and favorite
Brasserie of the French president
amid clashes between protesters and
police
on the 11th day of Nationwide strikes
over pension reform plans to raise the
retirement age to 64.
this is a regular snapshot of discontent
pervading much of France
talks between unions and the French
prime minister Elizabeth Bourne broke
down
they live in a parallel reality it's
incredible they have to stop thinking
that they can rewrite history and change
reality what happened is that
yesterday's meeting was a slap in the
face for the government we slapped the
door because Elizabeth Bond refused to
withdraw the reform we told her from one
voice that if this reform was not
withdrawn we could not talk about
anything else
macron's argument the country can't
afford the current pension system is
rejected on Mass
with continuing Fury over a decision to
force reform through without a vote
we won't give up until they take the
time to listen until they reconsider
their decision We Won't Give Up
the Constitutional courts will rule on
the legality of legislation next week
until then a fierce dissent promises to
rage on Adele Robinson Sky News
the UK steel industry has been in
Decline for years not just a job but a
way of life already lost for many former
workers unions have warned that without
immediate action from the government
steel companies may never be able to
recover now many are calling for more
investment to revive the sector our
economics and data editor Ed Conway
reports
Alan is one of a long line of Steel
Workers in Port Talbot his father and
his father's father worked here turning
rock into iron and then into steel now
with the fate of the plant uncertain
he's worried that this is the end of an
era my grandfather worked in the core
governs my father worked on a blast
furnace and my boy worked in the coal
Mill there now the town has shrunk you
know the the you look at Station Road
the shops and that it's not what it used
to be but we'd like to hang on to what
we got there and the fear is that if
anything happened to the steel industry
is going to drive youngsters out the
portal but
steel is the backbone for the modern
world if it's not made of steel it's
made with steel but refining it from
Iron Ore as they do here in South Wales
is a dirty business
that firework effect you can see behind
me into those tiny little pieces of
molten iron coming out from the base of
this glass furnace inside there
temperatures over 2 000 degrees that's
what you need to turn Solid Rock into
molten liquid iron that's pouring out
from the base of here but the Striking
thing about this is actually iron is
kind of the side product here for every
ton of Steel produced here there are two
tons of carbon
are the Indian company which now runs
the site says its best hope of survival
is to pull down the two massive blast
furnaces and replace them with Greener
electric Arc furnaces but it won't come
cheap and at once government help
s support we're asking for investment
at this point of time
governments in Europe are throwing
billions of money into our competitors
industry in Germany in France in Spain
and we are only asking for a similar
deal so we want to have fairness a fair
deal for our communities for our people
the government has offered 300 million
pounds Tata wants a billion or more but
even this won't save all the jobs with
only around a thousand of the 4 000
likely to survive
that's not the only challenge facing the
industry in Rotherham they already make
steel the way they want to in South
Wales but Britain's high energy costs
make it hard to compete
then the day I think we're still about
30 percent above what the continent is
they are trying to to close that Gap to
make us at least competitive with the
continent and I think we'll get there is
it soon enough
probably not
elsewhere still works at closing or
cutting their Workforce no other country
in the world safe for Venezuela has seen
steel production fall as fast as Britain
this country could become the first
developed economy to shift completely to
low carbon steel production but even
this won't save all the jobs for the
workers here another year of uncertainty
looms Ed Conway Sky News
Hospital leaders in England say they're
seriously concerned about how patient
safety will be maintained during next
week's Junior doctor strikes members of
the British Medical Association will
walk out for four days from Tuesday NHS
officials are warning the strikes will
have a severe impact on services
a man who murdered his pregnant wife by
pushing her off a landmark in Edinburgh
has been jailed for at least 20 years
Javid at fosia Javid died when she was
pushed off of the seat in 2021 police in
Leeds described the actions of Kashif
Anwar who is 29 as incomprehensible
doctors treating Italy's former prime
minister Sylvia Berlusconi have
confirmed he's suffering from a lung
infection brought on by leukemia the 86
year old is in intensive care at a
hospital in Milan after suffering
breathing problems it's understood he's
responded well to treatment following
his admission yesterday
a new Nationwide emergency alarm system
is to be tested for the first time on
Sunday the 23rd of April the tone will
play across millions of phones in the UK
and will be used to warn people in
life-threatening emergencies Ashner
hurunak has the details
it's hardly a reassuring sound but it is
designed to get our attention a 10
second alert that will be sent to every
mobile phone across the country in a
life-threatening emergency that the
government is trialing there will be
many people that see this as part of a
slightly alarmist process of of us
worrying about a coming War perhaps I
think that's a red herring actually
other things like flooding events
theoretically in certain places at
certain times this this could be useful
could save lives particularly if things
get this bad its primary use will be the
serious weather-related incidents it
does flood here quite a lot of things so
yeah it'd be quite a good idea I can see
the benefits of it definitely in terms
of
like making everybody aware of the same
thing at the same time
this technology is so specific it has
the ability to Target local people the
river behind me is prone to flooding if
it did local people could be notified
and told perhaps to evacuate their homes
but this system also has the ability to
inform us of national incidents too
security whether or otherwise it could
for instance have been used last summer
when some 20 homes were destroyed in
wildfires that ripped through the
village of Weddington in East London
the system is already used
internationally but only when there's an
immediate risk to life
I think this just helps us to be better
prepared to deal with those
circumstances and in those circumstances
it could be the sound that saves your
life the domestic abuse Charities warned
for some it could do the opposite I'm
not sure that it's been fully
appreciated just quite how dangerous the
discovery of a hidden phone can be for
women and we need to do absolutely
everything we can to make sure that
everyone is aware that this is happening
and how to turn off
the notification can be turned off on
all devices and it doesn't tap into Data
the government says the alert on the
23rd of April is just a test if heard
after then it shouldn't be ignored
ashnaharanag Sky News
well we end News at 10 tonight with some
breaking news in the last hour and Euro
2022 winners England have beaten Brazil
on penalties in the first women's
finalisima at a sold-out Wembley Stadium
or Sky Sports News Joe Wilson joins us
now uh Joe what an end to a big match
tell us more yeah it was a really
brilliant match there was drama until
the end as you said um I sold out
Wembley it was all set up for the
lionesses to win another trophy at
Wembley and they did exactly that this
one ending one all in normal time to
force penalties it was Ella tune here
that opened the scoring in the first
half and in that first half England
really did look in control of the match
Brazil switched things up at half time
they changed tactics they really quieted
England down and look at that for an
equalizer in the third minute of
stoppage time of the 90 minutes what a
time to score to force this game into
penalties Mary erps the England goal
will be making a little bit of a fumble
at there but she made amends in the
penalty shooter water save from herbs
there you can see exactly what it meant
to her and then it was Chloe Kaylee that
stepped up to score the winning penalty
in some style to cue sale abrasions at
another trophy for the lionesses and of
course we are building up to this
Summer's World Cup England now 30
matches unbeaten they've got a game
against Australia on Tuesday next week
which at the moment will be their final
warm-up game before the World Cup but
what are we to go into the World Cup in
July on that 30 match on beaten streak
uh what a match and what a way to end
News at 10 Joe thank you